today on the matt walsh show the media
is shocked to discover that dads matter
apparently children need male role
models in their life maybe the nuclear
family isn't a patriarchal conspiracy
after all also the latest on the bizarre
and tragic alec baldwin story and the
treasury secretary now wants to levy
taxes on unrealized capital gains and if
you don't know why that's insane and
tyrannical i'll explain plus the white
house unveils its national gender
strategy whatever the hell that's
supposed to mean in our daily
cancellation i once again find myself at
the center of controversy and outrage
this time because i dare to suggest that
women should take their husbands last
names shocking stuff all of that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
so we begin the week with something
positive for a change this only happens
about once a year on this show so soak
it in while you can cbs new news aired a
report on friday about some unique
measures being taken at a high school in
louisiana to stop the violence and chaos
that had been plaguing the campus
southwood high school in shreveport
began the year in september with
multiple major bras brawls and and
fights and everything between between
students and over the course of just
three days over 20 kids were arrested
for assault and other charges
and that's when as the cbs report tells
us
the dads of the community decided to do
something about it let's listen
nobody here has a degree in school
counseling
no majors in criminal justice no no your
qualifications are fair
we decided the best people who can take
care of our kids or who for us
so michael lafitte started dads on duty
we're out doing what we do for our
babies a group of about 40 southwood
dads who now hang out at the school in
shifts that's a goal today any negative
energy that enters the building has to
run a gauntlet of good parenting what's
going on buddy you're moving fast i like
that horse i immediately felt a form of
safety we stopped fighting people
started going to class how could that be
you ever heard of a look a look dads
have the power to do that yes
not many people know it but yes
let's go let's go but it's not just the
firm stares and stern warnings let's
make it to class my son it's also the
dad jokes
they just make funny jokes like oh hey
your student's untied but it's really
not untied
they hate it they're so embarrassed by
it
and it's that perfect mix of tough love
and gentle ribbing that dads do so well
that has helped transform this school
the school has really just been like
happy and you can feel it
which is why the dads plan to keep
coming to southwood indefinitely because
not everybody has a father a father
figure at home or a male period in their
life so just to be here
makes a big difference do you think you
stumbled onto something here
absolutely have you stumbled onto
something he asks yes they've stumbled
onto something called fatherhood
see
you know i watch something like this and
i want to celebrate it i do celebrate it
dad's getting involved taking
charge of their children and their
communities
it's a beautiful site to behold
and yet i'm frustrated at the same time
that so many in our culture especially
those who control the narrative
can't connect the dots or refuse to
connect them
i mean the media will tell us
heart-warming stories like this and
they'll rightfully applaud the men
who've stepped up
then they'll write the whole thing off
as a gimmick an aberration or at best as
something isolated
sure lots of problems can be fixed when
dads get involved but only at school and
only when they're wearing matching
t-shirts and only when they give
themselves a clever name like dad's on
duty
then they'll go back to supporting
organizations like blm which has the
explicit goal of destroying the nuclear
family
and they'll go back to pretending that
men and women are interchangeable and
identical
and they'll go back to celebrating
single motherhood as the pinnacle of
parenting excellence
and they'll go back to calling you
racist if you suggest that many of the
problems about in the black community
stem from the scarcity of fathers in the
home
see this this dad's on duty thing is
then relegated to a cute little human
interest story a nice two-minute
video that can go viral on twitter the
broader societal implications are
ignored
because they in the media they're not
they're not going to stop to ask
you know why this school experienced
a seemingly miraculous change simply by
the physical presence
of firm and attentive men on school
grounds
this this cognitive dissonance goes
beyond the media they're the ones
driving it purposefully but there are a
lot of normal people in our society who
struggle with this same disconnect
i couldn't help but notice lots of the
accounts with blm in their bio
we're sharing this video apparently not
realizing that the content of the video
directly contradicts and flies in the
face of the stated goals of the
organization they pledge allegiance to
but if we're able to somehow lift our
heads above this
swirl of contradictions we'll see that
the dads in shreveport
are not some anomalous case nor are they
living in a cultural vacuum
this is this is true universally
children need fathers preferably their
own fathers and if they can't have their
own fathers either because he's dead
or worse he has chosen to abandon them
then they need male leadership somewhere
else a child who grows up with no male
leadership at all
a child who is raised only by women this
is a lot of kids
will be severely disabled
psychologically emotionally and
spiritually
that's not because the female influence
is bad for a child but because the
female influence is only one half of the
complete picture it's one half of the
recipe
a child can survive physically on half
but he'll be
deeply
malnourished so what is it that dads
bring to the table why why can't they be
so easily replaced why do why do they
leave an enormous hole behind when they
abandon
their posts
well we see it in the clip that was just
played for one thing dads are a more
imposing and formidable presence
and they exud they exude that aura
naturally
you know kids are almost always better
behaved when dad is around it's not
because they don't respect mom but
because they see mom as a gentler and
more empathetic presence
it's crucial that they have such a
presence in their lives but there's a
flip side to every coin especially in
parenting and the flip side in this case
is that they think they can get away
with more they think they can be a
little bit looser they can push more
boundaries with mom
unless dad is there but a good dad is
not just stern he's not solely an
authority figure dads can be playful and
irreverent in a unique sort of way again
moms have that role as well but it
manifests in different ways
and then of course there's the most
important
dad contribution or one of the most
important contributions
for a boy specifically dad is around
to show him how to be a man 95
of this job has to be done through
demonstration not lecturing
and as a boy grows older he might forget
almost everything his dad ever told him
but he won't forget the example that was
set for better or worse
the boys at that school in shreveport
most of them
have probably never had a man around to
show them how men are supposed to
conduct themselves
millions of boys are being raised in
this way on a sort of island and it
becomes very much a lord of the flies
situation
which becomes all the more pronounced in
urban schools
because these are boys who are walking a
path to manhood
with no man walking in front of them no
footsteps to follow no guidance of any
kind
the result then
is chaos
violence despair
almost every bad thing we see in society
drug abuse suicide
uh you know
crime violent crime all of it
stems back largely to this issue
and we really have no right to expect
any other result
when we remove male leadership
from society
now let's get to our five headlines
all right so um halloween's coming up of
course my kids have have already started
their 12
days of their of halloween really it's
like two weeks every holiday is like
this now i don't know if it's like this
for
in other families um and i'm always
pointing this out to my wife that
somehow these days kids at least my kids
celebrate each holiday like a dozen
times so my kids had a trunk or treat
thing over the weekend when that's just
where you go to a parking lot and ever
and they go and everyone's lined up in
their cars and they hand the candy out
um and they'll have another one this
week and then they have like a halloween
party with their friends i think and
then they've got actual halloween
every holiday is like this it's
celebrated in phases kind of like stages
of celebration
when i was a kid
the holiday was one day and that was it
and my parents sent me out on halloween
alone
with a pillow case
and i wandered the streets until about 3
a.m
and then i came back with nine pounds of
candy and half of it was poisoned and so
they'd have to throw it out
there was a lot of poisoning of candy
back when i was a kid that's not really
a thing that we worry about anymore but
back then
it was a big deal
that's how i remember it anyway my
memory might be slightly skewed um and
also holidays were so they were they
were simpler and they were more intense
but they were more humble also
like one year
um
and i remember this distinctly i wanted
to be a knight
in shining armor for
halloween a positive you know
positive halloween costume
but my parents didn't want to go out and
buy
one of those costumes and so my mom
took a cereal box and covered it in
aluminum foil
and uh put it on my head and that was my
and then i had a little plastic sword
and that was my night and shining iron
costume and then every single house i
went to they thought i was an astronaut
inside this conversation a million times
oh look at you cute little astronaut and
i'd have to say what what i have a sword
do you think i'm an astronaut with a
sword
and then i realized that would actually
be a cooler costume to be a a sword
wielding astronaut
anyway that was halloween back in the
day it's it's not the same for kids
anymore
so we uh we'll start with this
shocking
bizarre terrible news that you've no
doubt heard
many times over the weekend from the set
of a new alec baldwin movie um the
cinematographer and director were both
shot by alec baldwin the cinematographer
is now dead
because baldwin fired a
prop gun quote-unquote that apparently
had a live round in the chamber so
here's the latest on the story from tmz
it says the
the gun that claimed the life of helena
hutchins might have been more than just
an onset prop it was also being fired
recreationally
even when cameras weren't rolling
multiple sources directly connected to
the rust production which was the name
of the western they were filming rust
which obviously now will never see the
light of day
um
it says they tell tmz the same gun alec
baldwin accidentally fired hitting the
dpn director
was being used by crew members offset
for target practice
we're told this off the clock shooting
which is allegedly happening away from
the movie lot was being done with real
bullets which is how some who worked on
the film believed a live round found its
way on the chambers that day
um so here's the thing about this
originally
when i heard this story
you know i thought there's there's no
way you could blame baldwin for this
or hold him criminally liable in any way
because he obviously didn't know the gun
was loaded
and he was acting out a scene in a movie
or apparently now they were they were
practicing
a certain shot they were going to do in
the film where he's pointing the gun
directly at the camera
so we're in the
as the audience you're getting the
perspective of the person who's who's
you know about to be shot
um
and uh you know i thought was probably
fired
or held or used hundreds of prop guns
and dozens of movies over 20 or 30 years
of acting
and i assume never once did any of them
have actual bullets in them
so you can't blame him for what was
clearly a horrific accident
and i thought that
but then i learned number one
that he was the executive producer on
the film also not just the actor which
means his responsibility is increased
but the other important thing that i
learned
is that apparently from what i've read
since then
they usually don't and this is
maybe this is this is a dumb assumption
that i had i always assume that they use
fake guns on the sets of movies that
these are not real guns they're
basically like toy guns um but
apparently not they use real guns this
is what they do
this is what i've been told anyway most
of the guns they use in these in these
kinds of movies are real and um and they
but they're loaded with blanks
and that changes things
for me i think because
ignorantly i'd assume that they were all
fake guns like very realistic toy guns
um and then a lot of the sound and
everything is added in post-production
i don't know why they don't do that
i think probably now they they will
but if that's the case
and it's a real gun
um
then
the rules of gun safety apply and uh one
of the one of the main rules of gun
safety is that you assume you have to
assume every gun is loaded
which means once the gun is handed to
you
even if you've got a prop guy on set or
whoever
who tells you that it's a cold gun which
is apparently what they what they said
as they handed it to him it's a cold gun
there's no it's not there's no bullets
in it
um you still have to check yourself
which he didn't do
and so that goes back to his own
responsibility
now there are other complicating factors
here like we talk about the
the standard rules of gun safety and
there's been a lot of this commentary on
social media about oh rules of gun
safety
yeah but
we also have to acknowledge that that
many of the standard rules of gun safety
are
violated on a film set
i mean you're doing a lot of things on a
film set with a gun that you would never
do at a gun range
like pointing it at somebody else for
example i mean standard rules again
standard gun safety rules you never
point your gun
even if it's not loaded you never point
a gun at anything that you don't intend
to destroy on a film set they do that
all the time in the course of making the
movie
so not all of the normal rules apply but
this is one if they're using real guns
it has to you got to check it he didn't
check it
and um
i mean it's obviously there's no malice
involved here no one's accusing him of
doing it on purpose
but then it becomes it seems to me
not a legal expert but it comes very
similar to
having one too many drinks getting
behind the wheel of a car
and you kill someone and you're going to
go to jail for that
and i think that's what alec baldwin is
facing here i don't see how you get away
away from it
if he knew if he knew that it was a real
gun even if he thought that it was cold
or whatever
uh if he knew it was a real gun didn't
check it pulled the trigger
that's it
all right
let's move to this treasury secretary
danny devito has a new plan
along with wanting to monitor all bank
accounts with 600 in transactions which
is
almost all bank accounts probably like
90 of bank accounts
now she also wants to tax
quote unrealized capital gains
i.e net worth
let's listen to her make this case
i think what's under consideration is a
proposal that
senator wadden and the senate finance
committee have been looking at that
would
impose
attacks on unrealized capital gains
on
liquid assets held by extremely wealthy
individuals billionaires
i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at
capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
and
right now
escape taxation uh until they're
realized and often they're unrealized
and that death uh benefit from a
so-called step up of basis so it's not a
wealth tax but um a tax on unrealized
capital gains of exceptionally wealthy
individuals
this is truly the penguin's most
dastardly plot yet
and
it's not a wealth tax
well what the hell is it
secretary devito what is it if it's not
a wealth tax
this is we literally did that the
definition of a wealth tax
where you're taxing someone's net worth
their their overall wealth not their
income
so what that means is for example
um
your home
okay that's that's that would count here
as uh it's it's you haven't sold it but
it's part of your net worth
and when we talk about someone's
net worth if you own a home
the equity in the home that that all
factors in
and so you would get taxed on that
and you would get taxed on other you
know investments even if you haven't
sold
um you would still get taxed
which means going back to the house for
example and this would this would apply
to all i mean stock market everything
where you're getting taxed on
investments that you have not actually
sold
so the think about the phrase unrealized
capital gains
so these are gains that you have not
realized that that haven't happened
don't exist
it's not money that you actually have
when we talk about i think people have
this notion in their head when we talk
about someone's net worth
um
and we say i mean let's talk about the
billionaires for a second we say that
mark zuckerberg's net worth is a hundred
gazillion dollars or whatever it is
and i think most people don't understand
the first thing about basic economics
they imagine a scrooge mcduck vault in
his house
where he's got all of all of that the
100 gazillion dollars it's all in gold
coins in a vault and he just dives in
and swims through it
uh but that's not the case
we're not talking about how much cash he
has on hand or what what he has in his
checking account
we're talking about the value of
everything
that he owns or has a stake in
home business investments
they want to tax all of that
say they want to tax the your your real
estate investment which could be the
home you live in and that would mean for
a lot of people
if this if this trickles down
the tax to non-billionaires
that would mean you have to sell your
home to pay that tax
and when you sell your home you're
already getting taxed that is a taxable
event
in and of itself so then there's more
taxes that you're paying
it's it's total madness this plan
and the
the the
the scope
by the government
the expanse of government power and
oversight that would that would be
needed to enforce something like this is
is unthinkable it's it's difficult to
wrap your mind around it
to tax people based on their net
worth and if you think that this will
what they're telling us right now is
that this will only be the billionaires
keep in mind
the monitoring of transactions of 600 or
more they say that that is also focused
on the uber wealthy and the billionaires
they want to they you know they want to
smoke out all the billionaires that are
hiding transactions and so they're
starting at 600 bucks
rather than 60 000 bucks
or something more realistic if they're
if they're targeting billionaires
so
while they say that they want to go
after the billionaires
when it comes to the bank account
monitoring
there's going to be a whole lot i mean
tens of millions of middle-class people
swept up in that and not by accident
and i can guarantee you with this it'll
be the same damn thing
even if it starts with okay we're only
targeting this little sliver of one half
of one half of what one percent of
people those are the only ones affected
by this
it will expand from there how do i know
that
because it always does and i mean always
you look at the entire history of
taxation in the united states of america
or we could even
start with the with the uh with
the institution of the income tax
itself
and you could start there
and you will see that every single time
a tax is proposed including the income
tax itself it is always very very
limited
it's uh there's only this one little
small percentage of people that are
going to be affected by that by this and
even then
the the effect will be minimal
it starts there and then it increases
and increases increases
and the net
which is originally supposed to be this
very small net to catch a small number
of fish
has this habit of growing and growing
and growing until all the fish in the
sea are caught up in it that's the way
it always works always 100 of the time
and it'll be this way with this as well
because when you give the government
power
i mean i don't know how many times we
have to say it
when you give the government power
it will never give that power back ever
and it will always expand that power
so if in principle we say that this is
the kind of thing the government can do
and should do
which is to keep track of our net worth
and to tax us on things we haven't even
sold yet
um
you know to to tax you on the on the
sale price of something you haven't sold
if we say in principle it's the kind of
thing that the government can do then
then it's the kind of thing they can do
and they're going to keep on doing it
i mean i use phrases like total madness
to describe this but it's it's actually
not
this is this is not
madness at all this is a very considered
plan
with for them a definite endpoint
that they won't tell us
um
totally disastrous
and and and i i i know why
tyrants in the government would want to
do something like this
but i don't care where you fall on the
on
on the political spectrum which side of
the aisle you're on
[Music]
you are simply a brain dead
clown i mean you you have to be the
biggest [ __ ] on earth to go along with
something like this because it will it
will affect you too
unless you you live your whole life and
never own anything
okay if you live your whole life
never never owning anything never
investing in anything
you know always
living in homes other people own
never having any permanent
no permanence at all no ownership
if you live your life that way then then
you wouldn't be affected by this
and that is in fact
how the government would like us to live
all right what else we got here so the
white house has just announced
a national gender strategy
um and this is a big announcement and
camilla harris made the announcement
over the weekend
and i'm looking right now at
whitehouse.gov it's their fact sheet on
the national strategy on gender equity
inequality
um
and uh it says
let's see here
the strategy identifies ten
interconnected priorities
uh one economic security two
gender-based violence three health for
education five justice and immigration
six human rights inequality under the
law
seven security and humanitarian relief
eight climate change nine science and
technology and ten democracy
it says these priorities are inherently
linked and must be tackled in concert
and of course it also adopts an
intersectional approach that considers
the barriers and challenges faced by
those who experience intersecting and
compounding forms of discrimination and
bias related to gender race and other
factors including sexual orientation
blah blah blah yadda yadda
so this is their gender strategy to to
combat uh
you know
gender related discrimination and to in
the institute
uh
gender equity inequality
and we're looking at all these areas
that have nothing to do with gender
whatsoever
climate change
what in the world does that have to do
with gender climate change we we all
live
on on the same planet
and whether there's man cause climate
change or not and to what degree it's
happening and
whether we're
barreling towards an apocalypse in 10
years or 12 years or 15 years or
wherever they move the goal posts to
you you would think that we're all
equally as affected by it
you know if
if
if half of the country is going to be
under water in the next 10 years
i think whether you're man or woman
i mean i i don't think that
that that has anything to do with with
uh with you know stopping you from
drowning are me are men more likely are
we better at floating
are we are we more floatable i don't
know
uh so of course not none of these have
anything to do or you know
nine of the ten have nothing to do with
gender whatsoever
uh
but this also goes back and you know i
have to to point it out because i simply
have to that
they they have a whole plan for helping
women and
[Music]
making sure that women aren't just
killed by climate change forget about
the men
and they have this plan and yet
they don't know what a woman is and
that's that's a problem and you that
should be
before you can institute a plan like
this you would think number one you
should have to define your terms but of
course they can't do that all right next
attorney general merrick garland
continues to prove himself to be a shill
and an ideologue and wholly unfit for
the job
um
thank god the republicans prevented this
nutcase from getting on the supreme
court by the way it's one of the one of
the only real accomplishments and it was
an accomplishment one of the only real
accomplishments of the republican party
in the last 20 years has been keeping
this guy off the supreme court but
unfortunately they couldn't stop him
from getting um
in the department of justice at the top
of the department of justice as the
attorney general so here's the latest
from merrick garland
along with our partners at the consumer
financial protection bureau
and the office of the comptroller of the
currency
we are also announcing our first
settlement under the initiative
and our second redlining settlement in
the last two months
redlining contributed to large ratio to
the large racial wealth gap
that exists in this country
the practice made it extremely difficult
for people of color to accumulate wealth
through the purchase refinancing
or repair of their homes
that discrepancy in wealth is clearly
reflected in current home ownership
rates
today a white family is 30 percent more
likely to ha
own a home than a black family
this present-day gap in homeownership
rates is larger than it was in 1960.
well yeah and they want uh black
families to own more homes so that they
can tax them into bankruptcy like the
rest of us which is what their plan is
but this raises the question of why is
the attorney general
talking about home ownership
and racial discrepancies in home
ownership
and this relates to another clip that
that may not at first seem to be related
but we all i'm going to play this for
you then we'll tie it all together
uh here's obama
stumping for terry mcauliffe in virginia
and they are they're floundering and
they're desperate and they're panicked
in the mcauliffe campaign and that's why
they're bringing i mean they're bringing
in everyone they can
almost none of them actually live in
virginia uh bringing them all in
to stump for terry mcauliffe but here's
obama
dismissing
concerns on the right especially about
school boards
as just a bunch of phony culture war
stuff
we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media's pedals to juice
their ratings and the fact that he's
willing to go along with it instead of
talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
that's not what you need virginia
instead of forcing our communities to
cut back at a time when we're just
starting to recover we should be doing
more to support people who are educating
our kids and keeping our neighborhoods
safe
[Applause]
uh you want to support people who are
keeping the neighborhood safe we mean
police officers
but but of course this this
coward
you know wants to
he's obfuscating a little bit he's not
going to be directing what he's saying
but it's very clear especially at the
end there
that what he's saying is that the the
parents showing up at school board
meetings are participating in a phony
right wing
culture war this is all trumped-up
outrage
so parents who go to school board
meetings
because they're concerned about they're
getting involved in their children's
education and they're concerned about
what their kids are being taught that's
phony outrage
and and uh and especially
in loudoun county
where parents are upset because a girl
was raped in a bathroom
and the loudoun county school board
covered it up according to barack obama
that's phony outrage
to worry about girls getting raped in
school
barack obama says is phony outrage
it's phony culture war stuff
and this coming from someone on the left
and it's all it it is always absurd
anytime anybody on the left especially
obama of all people accuses anyone else
of participating in a phony culture war
phony outrages that's all they do
that is all they do every single day
is invent new
battlegrounds for the culture war
that's it i mean that is really it
the attorney general's exactly what he
was doing
talking about uh you know finding here's
another battleground for the culture war
racial discrepancies in homeownership
this is their version of leadership
pete budageage transportation secretary
we're in the middle of a of a of a
supply chain crisis
he's still
still on paternity leave but but he took
time to do an interview a couple days
ago
and uh he said that now he's he's really
focused on raising awareness about
paternity leave
another culture war issue he's a
transportation secretary
why is he talking about forget about the
fact that he went on paternity leave and
is still on paternity leave for two
months and counting
why
why is he talking about about that on
cable news
the trans well because that's this is
all they do
as far as they're concerned this is
their entire job
phony outrages
cult
culture war issues
on every level
i mean we we played that uh clip
of the teacher in uh i forget with
riverside i think in california
the trigonometry teacher doing the
sohcahtoa dance with the indian feather
headdress she was you know kind of
having a mental breakdown
in the middle of school and now she's
been suspended and we and and i did
defend her on the basis that like she's
this is a mnemonic device and she's
trying to get the kids to remember
sohcahtoa and as i said i i remember it
you know a few days later those kids
will never forget that she and she
imprinted it in their minds and so she
was successful in that way but she was
suspended you can make an argument for
suspending her because because it was it
was a little bit of a psychotic break
that she appeared to have uh in the
middle of class but
they
left-wing activists
showed up at the school
and held a rally
and you know i was looking at some of
the pictures of them they got they got
the fist raised you know they've got
their poster board signs they're
marching outside the school
about this
because of some weird awkward
video of a of a trigonometry teacher
chanting sokatoa this is what we're
rallying you're you're rallying over
this you made signs about this
yeah because it's insensitive to native
americans
even that
even that where everyone agrees that
it's bizarre like fine you suspend her
no one cares
um i'm the only i think i'm the only
person in the country who actually
defended her
and for me it's a very mild defense
even that becomes a battleground for the
culture even that's an opportunity for
phony outrage
because this is all they do
uh what else we got here i guess i
should mention this headline big deal um
it says the cdc is very carefully
monitoring the delta plus variant
so that's a thing now
and it's terrible honestly you know i'm
pretty shaken
by the delta plus
because the last thing we need right now
in the world is another
streaming service we've got enough of
those delta plus actually delta plus
sounds more like an upgrade you pay for
on the plane to get free wi-fi and more
legroom or something
i'll tell you what delta plus doesn't
sound like
it doesn't sound like anything you need
to worry about
um uh one other thing i wanted to
mention speaking of speaking of phony
outrages
uh going back to the dave chappelle
story very briefly
i just want you to get ready for this
because the cave is coming uh here's
from the new york post it says dave
chappelle said he's willing to sit down
with netflix employees who organized a
company walkout earlier this week in
protest of controversial jokes that he
made in his comedy special
in the show uh blah blah blah we already
know about that um but now his team is
saying that they uh they want to sit
down and they want to they want to they
want to have a conversation with the
with the protesters and they're
complaining that you know the protesters
don't want to sit down and have a
conversation and yahoo has this it says
that dave dave stands by his art a
spokesperson for chappelle tells yahoo
entertainment
both sides of the street are talking and
dave is listening at some point when
everyone is open i'm sure our
communities will come together as dave
said in his special no more jokes about
transgenders until we can all laugh
together i bring this up only again so
that you could prepare yourself uh if
you had latched on to dave chappelle as
some sort of uh champion
some sort of warrior against cancel
culture
get ready for the fact that he will cave
he already he already has really with
this response saying okay no more jokes
like that
let's sit down and talk
that's already i think kind of a cape
and um
the reason
why i think that cave is inevitable is
that he's getting little support from
the people that he likes and whose
respect and admiration he desires like
his fellow comedians other celebrities
there have been have there been any
major comedians who've come out
in defense of dave chappelle maybe there
have been a couple but
even guys like you know bill burr jerry
seinfeld who have spoken out against
cancer culture in the past have they
said anything maybe they have
um but he's getting very little support
from from that crowd
meanwhile he's getting a lot of support
from people he doesn't like
okay like us he doesn't really like us
as conservatives
and if you want to know how he really
feels about us then go back to one of
his other one of his other recent
specials
uh what he said about candace owens
that's how he feels about conservatives
especially female conservatives
and also the actual comedy special
itself
i think tells you where this is headed
because i i hadn't watched it until this
past weekend
and i i finally said okay i'll sit down
and watch
some of it and i watched most of it
but i didn't finish it because honestly
first of all it wasn't that good uh
there weren't many jokes
it's not really a stand-up special it's
more of a ted talk
there just aren't that many jokes and
many of the jokes that he does tell that
are pretty good
have already been told a bunch of times
on twitter and i know because i told
some of them
like his bit about the baby you heard
that you heard that bit on this show
like a month ago
um not saying he plagiarized it more
that just these are jokes that have been
out there and uh you know the stuff he
said about caitlyn jenner women winning
woman of the year yeah that's absurd but
we've all
that observation has been made many
times
um
but more importantly the whole thing to
me
and what kind of surprised me about it
but i wasn't expecting based on the
reaction is that the whole thing seems
like a kind of a maya culpa
it's very defensive
him kind of explaining himself
and he really wanted the audience to
know that he's not a bad guy he's not a
big that's a lot of it was was him
defending himself against claims of
bigotry
he spent a lot of time trying to
convince people of that
so it was not the in-your-face
bold kind of
politically incorrect spectacle that
it's been made out to be not at all not
even close
so get ready for that all right
and now get ready for our reading the
comments section
who's rocking polka dots
jonathan swank says these pronouns are
not even pronouns anymore these people
are just egomaniacal attention seekers
at this point
well i only take exception with your at
this point
qualification there that's that's what
it's
always been
that's what that's what gender ideology
gender theories has always been about
it's but it's been about
narcissism
uh big boy says i can't believe i'm here
wishing physical bullying was still
around
yeah i i think that you you do find
evidence of that that there are a lot of
people
who
never got punched in the nose because we
took this
zero tolerance policy towards any form
of
violence at all and if there's even a
fight you know everyone gets suspended
no matter who was responsible for it and
who started it
um
and uh and and we do see some of the
fruits of that
that there is
an advantage
to getting punched in the nose at a
certain age
and you'll learn some lessons from that
and a lot of kids have never had that
experience
uh
joy says i wonder what the advertisers
think of matt's advertising skills
wonder if they ever watch these clips
and just squirm when he said when he
says those eye bags are disgusting get
this product
unlike the normal advertising
commercials his actually bring me to
tears and make me feel the need to buy
the product if i ever want to leave the
house again well thank you
i break you down psychologically
try to embarrass and humiliate you and
shame you
into buying the product and that's that
is one strategy that i think really
works
um
cool papa j magic says over the last
couple of months matt seems much more
willing to share his personal life and
feelings with us what changed well i
started drinking heavily before each
show so i think that probably is what
did it
um
female casey royals fan says matt if you
want the dog to like you you should get
him a my pillow brand dog bed
uh no i'm not gonna do that and me and
the dog are not on speaking terms right
now because he ate um
the our remote and
so
i actually my wife and kids were out of
town for the night
and uh i was looking forward to you know
just relaxing and i i went downstairs
for me i came back up
and the dog had had just had eaten the
remote and so
really that meant that if i wanted to
turn the tv i had to get up and like
physically turn it on and it was it was
a whole big
deal this is what i get
for trying to befriend this dog
uh derek says surely matt must now
realize there's no going back from the
decision to decorate for halloween i'm
fully expecting a festive office for
every holiday now yeah i understand
that's i understand what sort of
toothpaste i've squeezed out of the tube
here and that's that's the way it's
gonna go it's fine
uh fat daddy says my name is legion for
for we are many my pronouns are liege
legions legion self
well done
don smith says uh matt needs to talk
about people who are faking mental
illnesses more like multiple personality
syndrome and tourette's it's truly
disgusting stuff and it's very hilarious
at the same time i don't think it's it's
intentional faking in most cases just as
i don't think the enormous spike in
gender dysphoria is in most cases
intentional faking i think
the human mind is incredibly susceptible
to suggestion and we all know that
that's where
you know that's the stock and trade of
hypnotists um
is it's through suggestion
so if you think about it
you can actually manifest
physical symptoms of an illness in your
body by convincing yourself that you
have that illness
your mind can create physical symptoms i
know that i can so you have one set of
symptoms let's say then you look it up
on webmd and it says that well if you
have those symptoms along with a
stomachache
that means that your illness is the
black plague and you'll be dead at 36
hours and then what happens you say oh
no you know what actually my stomach
does kind of hurt so if our minds can
create physical sensations
through the power of suggestion
how much more can our mind manifest
deluded mental states
through the power of suggestion
and that is
that is that explains a great percentage
of the gender dysphoria and everything
we see in the in the culture today
um
finally from flk matt you've given a lot
of commentary about planes but you've
yet to discuss the issue of airplane
bathrooms why are they designed so that
only a child can fit comfortably in them
i don't know i mean i don't think
they're designed for children at all i
mean you ever try to take a child you
ever had this experience
try to take a child to a bathroom on a
plane
um and now there's two of you inside
this little
this little box
and if it's a boy that you're taking in
the bathroom well he's standing
while he's doing his business and um he
already has issues with aim because he's
you know a small child
and but and and that's on solid ground
and now you're in a plane and it's
shaking up and down and it's really just
a recipe for dessert i can remember
taking my son it's probably a tmi but i
remember taking my son to a bathroom on
a plane when he was about four or five
years old and i don't want to get too
graphic but it was it was um
it was like a sprinkler system in there
and you know it just it was
and i'm going to him stop get it in the
toilet in the toilet and he's going i
can't daddy i can't
and it just got everywhere and i had to
clean it up and there's a backlog of
people waiting to get into the into the
restroom
um
it was very difficult
parenting
in a bathroom is a whole other subject i
could write a memoir about that but uh i
won't get into it right now
let's get to our daily cancellation well
speak of the devil i once again get to
tell you about one of my favorite
sponsors jen yousell
and the reason why i love janusel so
much is that i am tired of walking
around
and seeing all of these people with
these hideous disgusting bags under
their eyes that i am for i think as a
personal affront to me
i'm the one that has to look at you
and maybe you need to look at yourself
in the mirror and see what you look like
and that's why you need genusell plant
stem cell therapy for bags and puffiness
under the eyes rosa from new jersey
wrote uh somewhere to someone i felt the
bags under my eyes firm up and the skin
was glowing your product helped me to
reduce puffiness very fast in a couple
weeks i stopped using concealer because
of the improvement actually i've gone a
week without applying heavy makeup i
would recommend to anyone i've noticed a
great difference and look with its
instant effects you'll see results in as
little as 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back you will see within 12 hours
that
women and children stop
running and screaming in terror at the
sight of your hideous face
plus for new younger and wrinkle-free
skin shamany will also give you the
legendary genusell xv wrinkle treatment
absolutely free just for trying jen
yourself today so order now and save big
on genusell all packages are up to 50
off go to genusell.com enter matt30 for
an extra 30 off today that's
genusell.com genusell.com and if you
want to wake up to the facts rather than
the legacy media's neatly spun lies then
i highly recommend our newest morning
podcast morning wire not only has it
been topping the app on spotify charts
since its release it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and start a and rather leave
a five star review if you like what you
hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
now once more i find myself on the
defensive side of the ball in this
cancellation though as always the
objective is to make a play get the
turnover put the offense on defense
that's why i'm playing in the dime right
now six dbs on the field free safety
back deep ready to grab the pick kind of
losing track of the point i was trying
to make with this analogy
anyway the point is this weekend i was
again the subject of outrage and this is
embarrassing for me as someone who's
normally quite meek and gentle and
non-confrontational prefers to shrink
away from the spotlight i also consider
myself to be a people pleaser and i have
other deluded ideas about my own
personality but we won't continue down
that path right now what upset the
internet this time is a discussion that
began on this podcast on friday i read a
comment from a listener during the
reading the comments segment of the show
where he asked whether his fiancee's
refusal to take his name upon marriage
should be considered a red flag
and i said that not only is it a red
flag but it's a deal-breaker as a man i
would not marry a woman who didn't want
to share my name i would recommend that
other men draw the same line
now i repeated this point on twitter
later that afternoon everything that
followed is therefore really the fault
of the listener who brought this subject
up i hope you're happy sir look at what
you've done
this is on you
so over the course of the next three
days a familiar chain of events followed
thousands of people very upset that i
would suggest that women ought to take
their husband's name the fact that i
would
call this issue a deal breaker was all
the more abhorrent to the outrage masses
they've let me know that i'm a sexist a
misogynist a bad husband a tyrant a
bigot a barbarian
one guy said that my opinion on the
subject is evidence
that i might be murderous and actually a
physical danger to my family
just because i want to share my name
with them
others went a different direction saying
that my my perspective proves that i'm a
sexually repressed virgin
a fact that will no doubt come as a
great shock to the mother of my four
children
but rather than give a general overview
overview i think it'd be helpful in this
case
to read a few of these specific
responses and this i think is a good
representative sample
i'm choosing only from the blue check
squad verified accounts media people
authors academics and so on so here are
a few of them here's what they were
saying uh bethany says
i really don't hold much importance to
my surname a random name my granddad
chose in a pub after moving to england
my mom has a different surname now too
but i definitely would keep my name just
to spite angry men
steph says this is so toxic women do not
belong to men therefore it isn't a
requirement for us to be branded with
your surname it's a woman's choice it's
rare to hear of men taking women's
surnames so if you won't do the same for
us keep quiet lol rachel says would
consider it a deal breaker if any
boyfriend expected me to take his name
women have their own identities any man
who expects a woman to give hers up for
him without discussion clearly doesn't
fully grasp that heather says damn how
do i break it to my fiance that after 11
years we're gonna have to end things
because i'm not planning to change my
name is that something i do over text or
and amy says i'm amy alcon i've always
been amy alcon and even if i weren't an
author etc marriages may come and go i'm
me for a lifetime
and my name reflects that
of course the really funny thing about
all this and most of the rest of the
responses from feminists on the subject
is that they all seek to prove that
they're strong and independent women by
refusing to take their husbands names
and instead keeping their father's names
quite literally participating in the
patriarchy while pretending to dismantle
it
the other thing almost as funny
is that each response only underscores
rather than undermines the original
point i was trying to make
bethany says that she would refuse to
take her husband's name purely out of
spite
now fortunately for her this probably
won't ever come up
i mean she can she can actually force
her cats to take whatever name she wants
to give them but still she confesses to
being being driven by spite
steph and rachel see the unity of
sharing a name as branding
they would consider it a deal breaker in
the other direction if their future
husband dared to request that they have
a shared family name
heather says that she's getting married
to her boyfriend after 11 years
and doesn't plan to take his name 11
years
this is someone whose commitment issues
are probably terminal at this point
doubly so for amy alcon who says
again marriages may come and go
so you see in these answers
not just that cat ownership tends to
make women very bitter but also
evidence of two other things
one
that the trend to move away from sharing
the husband's name
is driven primarily by an ideologically
fueled hatred of our cultural traditions
and two
that it's a symptom of a society that
fears commitment
so let's talk about both of these in
reverse order
starting with two
marriage if it's anything worth doing
is the bonding of two people into one
marital unit
it is a union
it is a decision to share your life and
even in many ways to share your identity
with somebody else
it's not that you lose your identity
when you get married but rather that
your identity has changed and it's
bonded to this other person fulfilled by
them and by the love you share
if this all sounds like a bunch of uh
hocus-pocus to you that's fine
but please don't ever get married i mean
why would you if you don't believe in
what i'm saying then you don't believe
in marriage and the worst thing you can
do when you don't believe in marriage is
get married
if you do believe in marriage
then the very first thing you should do
the very first thing you should want to
do
is come together under the same name
is this a symbolic move yes but marriage
is symbolic it's real but it's also
symbolic
your name is real and also symbolic
you know what so we know what sharing a
name symbolizes it it symbolizes unity
commitment togetherness a shared life
what then does not sharing a name
symbolize
you can't say it symbolizes nothing it's
gonna symbolize something
that the decision to keep your own name
is a symbolic gesture in its own right
what is it symbolizing it symbolizes
separation detachment disunion
names are important everyone recognizes
that at some level the left recognizes
it which is why they make such a big
deal out of demanding that people
respect the new name of a trans person
after they quote transition
to call somebody by their old name their
dead name as it's called is an egregious
offense why because names matter
the symbolism in a name is profound john
proctor in the crucible would rather be
marched to the gallows than sign his
name on a false confession he was
willing to give the false confession
he was willing to have the whole town
told that he gave it
but he couldn't sign his name on the
paper he chose death rather than that
why because it's his name it's it's the
name that his sons will carry down to
their children and through the ages
he couldn't stand a sullied
in our deluded yet materialistic and
utilitarian age we don't understand
things like dignity and symbolism we
pretend not to even understand why the
symbolism of a shared marital name is so
crucial
yet the people on that side admit to the
truth when they say something like
marriages come and go they see marriage
as temporal and fleeting while names are
deep and rich and permanent
but marriage is supposed to be deep and
rich and permanent also which is why it
should be formed under a shared name
but then
why share the man's name and not the
woman's
well
a big part of the answer for me is that
i believe the man is supposed to be the
head of the family that may be
unfashionable to say but i you know i
care about fashionable opinions about as
much as i care about the outrage from
childless cat ladies but putting that
aside here's another reason
because it's a significant and enduring
cultural tradition
as already established we live in a
utilitarian age
and also a stupid and shallow age so we
tend to look at tradition as totally
unimportant
superfluous or worse we think that it's
noble to break traditions just for the
sake of breaking them we hate traditions
we feel oppressed by them because
traditions come from our ancestors and
we think that our ancestors should have
no say in how we live our lives even
though we live in the civilization they
gave us
i reject that attitude
i despise it actually
i think that if you're going to
dismantle a tradition
you better have a good reason
and the reason shouldn't be indifference
or spite
or half-baked notions of female
empowerment
you know gk chesterton said that you
know there are many fences in the world
that are worth tearing down but you damn
well better understand why the fence was
erected before you demolish it
tearing down fences on a whim
because they obstruct the path you
wanted to walk is foolish and arrogant
and a good way to get your face eaten by
a rottweiler
a similar thing can be said about our
cultural our cultural offenses our
traditions
which these days we dismantle with no
notion as to why no coherent reason
and the result is that we lose the
sturdy and beautiful things our
ancestors gave us and we replaced those
things with nothing at all sharing the
husband's name is among other things a
meaningful tradition dating back
centuries
there are those who want to discard this
tradition like they discarded so many
others which speaks not only to their
ignorance and their contempt for their
own history
and and the voice of their ancestors but
also for their disregard
it speaks to their disregard to for the
whole institution of marriage
that's why i said
what i said
and i stand by it
and why i say now to those who are upset
about it that you are once again
i'm terribly afraid to say
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show barack
obama tells americans they are wasting
time on break outrage while the
democratic party pursues a radical
equity agenda plus the biden
administration economic program goes
extreme that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen